البشر مرتبطون بانهم مخلوقات اجتماعيه
ولكن لا يزال هناك الكثير مما لا نفهمه
حول كيفيه تغيير ادمغتنا عندما نكون في
الشراكه مع احد دراسه حديثه من جامعه كيوف
في اليابان اظهرت انه عندما يعمل شخصان او
اكثر معا في المهمه نفسها فان المنطقه
الرئيسيه في ادمغه العاملين في فريق واحد
تصبح متناغمه اذا جازته هذه النتائج تشير
الى انه يمكن مطابقه النشاط العصبي لبعضنا
البعض عندما نكون في مجموعات وبحسب دراسه
عندما تعاون لاكمال المهمه فكانت النتيجه
كما لو كانت ديماغان يعملان معا كنظام
واحد لحل المشكلات بشكل ابداعي اقوى ربما
وبحسب ما جاء في الدراسه فان الادمغه تكون
في وضع من التواصل عندما يتحاور شخصان
يعملان معا
[موسيقى]
كلمه تيم ورك دائما احنا بنضيفها للسير
الذاتيه بتاعتنا او الملفات الشخصيه
وخصوصا على المواقع الاحترافيه مثل لينك
لما بنيجي ندي القدوس لحد او بنعطي
استحقاق دائما ما بنشير الى ان الشخص ده
تيم بلاير هذه الدراسه والتي اجريت في
اليابان ليست بجديده خليني ارجع لسنه 1970
عندما قام جيري تشرد
وهو شخص مهتم بالاورجنيزيشن او السلوك
المؤسسي وشاف انه الاهم من ان التيم ورك
بيعمل هارموني او انسجام ما بين اعضاء
الفريق لقى ان هو بيؤثر على قدرتهم
الابداعيه لو توفرت ثلاث شروط في الشركه
اول حاجه يكون بتاع الشركه او المؤسسه
واضح لكل اعضاء الفريق الاتجاه الشركه
ايضا يكون واضح وكمان السبورت او الدعم
اذا حدث بنسميه هيلثي كونفليكت او ما بين
اعضاء الفريق واللي دايما ما يحدث هل يفهم
من كلامك انه هناك اهميه كبيره للتفاعلات
الاجتماعيه لغه العيون التواصل اللفظي
وحدث التعبير الوجه فكلنا يعني لمسنا قد
ايه هي حاجه مهمه جدا وقت الكوفيد وقت
الكوفيد لما كلنا كنا بنعمل كل حاجه كلنا
كنا حاسين قد ايه
الاحتكاك والكلامس وموضوع ان احنا نكون
بنعيش في تيم ورك حتى لو احنا بنشتغل مثلا
هايبرد اللي هو نظام نص اونلاين ونص اوف
لاين ولكن الشركات حتى الملتي ناشونالز
اكدت على ان احنا لازم نلتقي فيه الحاجه
اسمها الاي سي ال هو بحدد ان الشركه دي
لها ايه الاكسبكتيشن بتاعتها او توقعاتها
ازاي ان احنا بنتكلم مع بعض وده مهم قوي
ولازم يكون التواصل فعال ما بين اعضاء
التيم ده والاي اللي هي لو بيحصل اكس
كيوشن لو انا بعمل المهمه او بعمل الخطه
اذا حدث شيئا ما بعمل ايه
[موسيقى]